F
OLD --
>> WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SATURDAY SHOW."
WITH CRIME SPIKING IN
DEMOCRAT-RUN CITIES LIKE NEW
YORK AND WASHINGTON, D.C., YOU'D
THINK FIGHTING CRIME AHEAD OF
THE MIDTERMS WOULD BE A
PRIORITY.
BUT ONE MEMBER OF THE SQUAD
DOUBLING DOWN ON DEFUNDING THE
POLICE.
>> IF YOU COULD DO IT AGAIN,
WOULD YOU STILL DOUBLE DOWN OR
USE THAT SLOGAN --
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> YOU WOULD?
>> WHILE DEMOCRAT-RUN CITIES
THAT AREN'T DEFUNDING THE POLICE
ARE PREVENTING CRIME.
IN WILMINGTON, DELAWARE, MURDERS
ARE DOWN 50% FROM 2021,
SHOOTINGS DOWN 25%.
THE DEMOCRAT MAYOR THERE SAYS HE
WOULDN'T EVEN CONSIDER DEFUNDING
THE POLICE.
UNFORTUNATELY, FOLKS IN CHICAGO
CAN'T SAY THE SAME THING.
AS CRIME SPIKES THERE, MAYOR
LORI LIGHTFOOT IS BUSY SINGING
KARAOKE.
♪ BABY, DON'T YOU WANNING THAT
GO -- WANNA GO.
♪ COME ON, COME ON, BABY, DON'T
YOU WANNA GO ♪♪ PRESSURE.
>> THAT'S PRETTY INSULTING, I
THINK, WHEN I SEE HER DOING THAT
CONSIDERING WHAT IS GOING ON IN
CHICAGO.
>> YEAH.
>> YOU'RE THE PERSON TO TALK TO
ABOUT.
>> YES.
>> YOUR BROTHER CHRISTIAN WAS
MURDERED, YOU'VE BEEN FIGHTING
FOR JUSTICE.
>> I'M DISGUSTED.
I DON'T KNOW IF SHE'S AUDITION
DECISION FOR THE MASKED SINGER
OR WHAT HER DEAL IS, BUT THIS IS
NOT WHAT I EXPECT AS THE LEADER
OF THE CITY OF CHICAGO, KNOWING
THE VIOLENCE THAT IS THERE.
THAT'S WHY WHEN I WENT TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., THOSE WHO HAVE
SAID DEFUND THE POLICE, THOSE
WHO HAVE SAID POLICE WASN'T
IMMEDIATED MT. NEIGHBORHOODS AND
YOU'VE SEEN THE -- NEEDED IN THE
NEIGHBORHOODS, I WANTED TO TALK
TO THOSE PEOPLE BECAUSE MY
LITTLE BROTHER CHRISTIAN'S
MURDER ON JUNE 24TH HAS
SHATTERED OUR FAMILY.
NOW WE NEED TO HOLD THOSE IN
LEADERSHIP TO ACCOUNT.
SO THAT'S WHAT I DID ON CAPITOL
HILL.
LET'S WATCH.
WE JUST WANT TO TALK ABOUT THE
CHI SIS OF WHAT HAS BEEN
HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY WITH
CRIME --
>> [INAUDIBLE]
>> CONGRESSMAN NADLER, CAN WE
SET UP A MEETING WITH YOUR
OFFICE AND HAVE A DISCUSSION?
>> MAYBE.
I'M GOING TO BE --
>> MAYOR LORI LIGHTFOOT DOING A
GOOD JOB?
>> I THINK SHE'S DOING A GOOD
JOB, AND I THINK SHE'LL BE
REELECTED AS MAYOR OF THE CITY
OF CHICAGO.
>> SENATOR, ANY REACTION TO THE
CRIME CRISIS IN AMERICA?
CRIME IS UP, SIR.
THERE'S A CRISIS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY REACTION?
YOU'RE A LEADER, I WOULD THINK
YOU WOULD HAVE A REACTION TO
WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE COUNTRY.
ANY REACTION TO RISING CRIME IN
AMERICA?
YOU SUPPORTED THE DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT.
IT LED TO THE RISE IN CRIME.
DO YOU HAVE ANY REACTION?
>> [BLEEP]
>> ANY REACTIONSOME NO
REACTIONSOME YOU KNOW, I WAS
JUST EXTRAORDINARILY
DISAPPOINTED WITH WHAT I SAW AND
THE INTERACTION.
THEY RAN AWAY FROM ME FASTER
THAN A NEW YORK CITY MAYOR --
MARATHON WINNER.
YOU GUYS ARE LEADERS, YOU
SHOULD, AND THIS IS EXTREMELY
DISACKING, AND THAT'S WHY I'M
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE MIDTERMS.
>> I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT,
THIS IS IF FROM THE CHICAGO
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
RISE MANY CRIME THERE FROM LAST
YEAR, 37%.
LARA, YOU AND I WERE TALKING
ABOUT CRIME DURING THE BREAK
RIGHT HERE IN NEW YORK CITY.
WE'VE SEEN A HUGE RISE IN CRIME
AS WELL.
PEOPLE ARE SCARED TO WALK AROUND
ON THE STREET, I AM ALL THE
TIME.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHAT NEEDS TO
BE DONE HERE.
PEOPLE LIKE LORI LIGHTFOOT ARE
JUST DIGGING HER HEELS IN.
>> AND THIS IS WHY FOR SO MANY
PEOPLE, THEY ALMOST FEEL LIKE
THIS HAS TO BE ON PURPOSE ON
SOME LEVEL.
HOW CAN YOU IGNORE WHAT IS GOING
ON?
GIANNO, HOW CAN THOSE PEOPLE --
LEADERS, AS YOU SAY, THE PEOPLE
WHO WE ARE SUPPOSED TO TURN TO,
TO HELP AMERICANS WHENEVER WE
ARE IN NEED, THEY WON'T EVEN
ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
YOU HAVE HERE MAYOR ERIC ADAMS
HERE IN NEW YORK CITY, JACKIE,
WHO HAS DONE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING
TO CURB THE VIOLENT CRIME, THE
MURDERS.
PEOPLE ARE TERRIFIED TO EVEN GET
ON THE SUBWAYS HERE IN NEW YORK.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE I DON'T KNOW
ANY OTHER EXPLANATION OTHER THAN
THEY'RE WANTING TO DISTRACT
PEOPLE FROM, YOU KNOW,
INFLATION?
THEY WANT TO DISTRACT -- I DON'T
KNOW, MAYBE THIS IS ALL PART OF
A STRATEGY FOR THEM.
BECAUSE I CAN'T IMAGINE HOW YOU
CAN LET CRIME GET SO OUT OF
CONTROL, NOT EVEN ADDRESS IT,
GIANNO, AND THEN HAVE NO PLAN TO
GET IT REINED BACK IN.
IT'S REALLY FRUSTRATING, AND
IT'S WHY SO MANY PEOPLE DO NOT
WANT TO LIVE MANY THESE BIG
CITIES ANYMORE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND IT'S GASLIGHTING, THAT'S
WHAT THEY'RE DOING.
77% OF AMERICANS SEE THIS AS AN
ISSUE.
>> YEAH.
>> IN CHICAGO LAST YEAR ALMOST
300 KIDS SHOT.
16 AND UNDER.
LAST WEEK, A 3-YEAR-OLD.
WHEN IS AN EMERGENCY FOR THEM?
IF WHEN IS IT?
>> I WANT TO TAKE A LISTEN TO A
SOUND BITE.
THIS IS NBC NEWS ON DEMOCRAT-RUN
CITIES LOSING POLICE OFFICERS.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> THE CONTROVERSIAL APPROACH TO
COMBATING ITS SHORTAGE OF POLICE
OFFICERS, HIRING CIVILIANS.
GOOD IDEA?
>> NO, NOT REALLY.
>> MIKE GLASER, WHO HEADS UP ONE
OF THE CITY'S POLICE UNIONS,
BLAMES MORALE FOR A CRUSHING
SHORTAGE OF ABOUT 6000 OFFICERS
FROM SEATTLE -- 600 FROM SEATTLE
TO ST. LOUIS, MAJOR CITIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE ALSO
REPORTING A COP STAFFING CRISIS.
>> SEAN, THIS IS HOW BAD IT'S
GOTTEN.
>> WHAT GIANNO DID WILL WAS
BASICALLY SAY THIS HAS BEEN A
PLANK OF YOUR PARTY'S PLATFORM
ALMOST.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT IT, AND
THEY RAN AWAY.
THEY WERE SO UNCOMFORTABLE
BECAUSE NO ONE EVER DOES THAT TO
THEM.
WHEN I WAS MANY CONGRESS, I HAD
MICROPHONES THROWN IN MY FACE
EVERY DAY LIKE THAT, SO I GOT
USED TO IT.
BUT THEY'RE NOT USED TO SOMEONE
ASKING THEM A VERY SIMPLE
QUESTION ABOUT A POLICY THEY
FULLY SUPPORTED.
I WONDER IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT,
DEFUNDING THE POLICE, CRIME HAS
SKYROCKETED, POLICE OFFICERS
HAVE LEFT THE FORCE, AND TO THIS
REPORT'S POINT THAT WE CAN'T GET
NEW PEOPLE IN, SO THE QUESTION
IS, IF WE WAITED A YEAR OR TWO
YEARS OR FIVE YEARS, IS CRIME
GOING TO SOMEHOW GO BACK DOWN
AGAIN?
WHAT ARE THEY THINKING?
IF WE JUST WAIT A LITTLE BIT
LONGER, IT'S GOING TO GET
BETTER?
I THINK MOST AMERICANS GO,
ABSOLUTELY NOT, THIS WAS A DUMB
POLICY FROM THE BEGINNING.
WE KNOW THAT COPS KEEP IT SAFE.
THERE'S BAD WITH CONGRESSMEN,
BAD BUSINESS PEOPLE AND BAD
COPS.
GET THE BAD COPS OUT.
BUT MOST OF THEM ARE GOOD MEN
AND WOMEN WHO SERVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND DON'T MAKE A LOT
OF MONEY.
THEY PUT THEIR LIVES IN HARM'S
WAY.
LET'S SUPPORT THEM.
I THINK IT'S GOING TO TAKE US,
YOU KNOW, YEARS IF NOT DECADES
TO COME BACK FROM THE DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT TO GET MEN AND
WOMEN TO VOLUNTEER TO SERVE
AGAIN.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> BOTTOM LINE, WE NEED POLICE
TO KEEP US SAFE.
I THINK MANY PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY UNDERSTAND THAT, AND
THEY WANT TO SEE IT COME BACK.
BUT WHEN YOU'VE DONE THIS KIND
OF DESTRUCTION AND DAMAGE, IT'S
HARD TO FIX IT X. IF THEN YOU
HAVE PEOPLE LIKE COREY BUSH ALSO
DOUBLING DOWN ON HER STANCE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
AND CRIMINALS ARE LOVING THIS,
BY THE WAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF THE DEMOCRATS
REALIZE THAT OR NOT, BUT THEY
LOVE THE DEFUND POLICE MOVEMENT,
THEY LOVE SOME OF THE POLICIES
LORI LIGHTFOOT HAS PUT IN PLACE.
THE NO CHASE POLICY, YOU CANNOT
GO AND CHASE THEM IN YOUR CAR
UNLESS YOU CALL IN YOUR
SUPERVISOR.
MEANWHILE, THE CRIMINAL HAS
GOTTEN AWAY.
YOU CANNOT CHASE THEM ON FOOT.
THIS IS A DESTRUCTIVE ERA IN
POLICY.
AND THAT'S NATIONALLY AND
LOCALLY.
WHEN ARE YOU GOING TO CHANGE
COURSE?
IT'S NOT WORKING.
THE FBI JUST CAME OUT WITH CRIME
DATA, AND THE WASHINGTON POST IS
SAYING, HEY, CRIME ISN'T A BIG
ISSUE, NO, IT'S NOT REALLY A BIG
ISSUE.
REALLY?
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
40% OF THE POLICE DEPARTMENTS,
NEW YORK AND LOS ANGELES, DIDN'T
EVEN SUBMIT DATA THE, AND CRIME
HAS GONE UP IN THOSE TWO PLACES,
SO WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT?
>> WHICH IS WHY REPUBLICANS ARE
RUNNING ADS ON CRIME, BECAUSE IT
WORKS.
MOST VOTERS, THIS IS A PROBLEM,
AND I WANT TO VOTE ON
POLITICIANSES WHO ARE GOING TO
KEEP ME SAFE AND TO THE EXACT
OPPOSITE OF THE DEFUND THE
POLICE DEMOCRATS.
>> AND CERTAIN POLITICIANS ARE
NOT GOING TO CHANGE THEIR STANCE
ON IT --
>> CORI BUSH IS ONE OF THEM.
>> -- THAT'S WHY T ONE OF